the washington football team is no
longer known by the name for which it
was known for 87 years it is currently
known
by no name other than the washington
football team the franchise apparently
threw its hands in the air yesterday
shireen and said we
can't dot the eyes we can't cross the
t's most importantly
we can't get the appropriate federal
trademark protections in place so we can
sell merchandise with the new name
on it so we're gonna wait to have a new
name and we're gonna play a
season at least a season with no name at
all
washington football team logos removed
from the helmet
washington placed under the nfl shield
on the front of the jersey
the uniforms look good they've got the
gold version
of the number on the side of the helmet
so they wouldn't look like alabama
i kind of like what it looks like
i don't like the fact that they
were sufficiently dysfunctional
shockingly
to not get a new name in place before
the start of the season
it has to be the first time in history
mike that the nhl has won up the nfl but
they did that yesterday and their timing
was impeccable with the naming of the
new seattle franchise the kraken
and i think they got a lot of publicity
out of that you know the marketing
director who
is new what a week or two into the job
said that you know these things take
you know 12 to 18 months seattle took
two years to do their name they went
through over a thousand names
they vetted a hundred names seriously
considered a hundred names looked at
polls looked online
i would have been more surprised i think
if they had got it done before the start
of the season
based on where we have come from i mean
they just announced at the beginning of
the month that they were going to do
away with the name
10 days ago they said we're definitely
not going to have it for this year and
now all of a sudden
they're supposed to have a new name when
they don't have trademark protections
all that stuff
it was really quick i would have been
more surprised that they had gotten it
done before the season they need time to
do this and and they're going to have
now a year they need to they need to
roll it out next spring for sure
we're on hiatus when this all came up
and
last week i remember seeing in the
washington post the first story hinting
at how long it takes to rebrand a sports
team because of all of the things you
have to do
and that's fine sharing everything you
said is perfectly reasonable
my position on that is this is part of
the debt you accrue
when you say in may of 2013 you're never
changing the name put it in all caps
and you don't plan for what is an
inevitability if you don't have the
foresight to realize
that your decision is the owner of the
team to dig in your feet
and pout and have a tantrum and refuse
to consider
that at some point you're gonna have to
change that name at some point during
your tenure as owner of the team
you're gonna have to change that name
you better have something ready in your
back pocket
for when your front pockets are emptied
that's why i have no sympathy
for daniel schneider here and look he
thought as of a couple of weeks ago
when they said when everyone expected
that
there would be new name out or old name
out new name in
that they're going to keep the old name
until they have a new name
they expected to have a new name like
you know even
even when it comes to the realities of
rebranding an nfl franchise
there was a level of defiance and
stubbornness from daniel snyder he
should have just acknowledged from the
get-go it should have been the plan from
the start
that we're going to go with this place
holder of washington football team
and it isn't going to be a short process
and it is going to take a year to a year
and a half
and it's almost like the owner had to
come to that conclusion on his own
before they could make it official which
maybe it should have been look
i mean there's all sorts of failures
here are we surprised
that a team that has been so
dysfunctional for the last two decades
could screw this up
they didn't see it coming and when it
was thrust upon them they didn't realize
that it wasn't something they would be
able to quickly do and now
three weeks in they finally cry uncle
and say we can't
come up with a new name this quickly
maybe they
should have never even tried to
well you know mike hashtag uh htt
wft doesn't have the same ring
a friend of mine a friend of mine is a
fan of the team and she reversed those
last letters you have to be careful
saying those last
letters but she reversed those letters
but you know
let's go back to when i was on last on
this show which was i don't know six
weeks ago two months ago whatever it was
and you were the first one saying look
this has to change and i
said yes i agree but you're the only one
banging this
this drum and it was a very soft drum at
that time mike you started banging and
it got louder and louder and louder and
once the sponsor said
we're out you've got to change this name
that's when it all happened the voices
all came together but we could all see
this coming i think
when you first started this chorus a
couple months ago and now it's happened
but you're right
he should have known that this was going
to come at some point this was going to
happen
at least start getting some trait
quietly get some trademarks of
of other things you think you might want
to change it to
what does that hurt to have those it
doesn't cost you very much money you
have them and then if it happens
you're ready to go if it does happen and
you know that's an excellent point
because
once it became inevitable that they were
changing the name
i started to research the u.s patent and
trademark
office's free database it's out there
for anyone it takes some
some work finding it and figuring out
how to actually do the search but it's
not all that complicated as evidenced by
the fact that i figured it out
but this guy martin mccauley who's made
a hobby out of squatting on
potential team names for the washington
franchise for
years the moment that it it was
announced that the team would be
conducting a thorough review of the name
back in
on july the 3rd he started loading up
the canon
with more of these names where he squats
on the trademark rights
and it shouldn't be look here's it
shouldn't be that hard
if the name they want is one of the
names that martin mccauley has
it shouldn't be that hard he's made it
clear that he doesn't want anything now
he said more recently he wants a
scholarship
to be funded for native american
students i mean i you know you have to
engage the guy to find out what he
really wants and i've gotten the
impression they refused to engage him
there's just been this stubbornness
intransigence defiance it characterizes
everything daniel snyder does
and this is what happens when it unfolds
in this context it ends up being
this this slippery elusive what in the
hell are you people trying to do
because you're not doing anything that
you need to be doing to lay the
foundation to change the name
so i'm not surprised by any thing that's
happened shireen i just have no sympathy
for daniel schneider that he's found
himself in this weird box where
he says he's going to conduct a thorough
review of the name he says he's going to
get rid of the current name
and replace it simultaneously with a new
name and then eventually has to say
this isn't going to work we're just
going to go with this
this placeholder washington football
team please buy our merchandise
for the washington football team but
just for this year by next year we'll
have
more merchandise that you can buy well
that's the thing they will sell more
more merchandise because they're going
to sell merchandise this year because a
lot of people like the look of
of of what it is and they have kept the
colors and then they'll sell much
more merchandise even next year so that
could have played a part in it too
this this could be a money-making
opportunity for for the franchise but
uh if it is not surprising that this is
where
this franchise is for sure and i'll say
this and
you can kind of tack onto this mike
whether you think that coming out with a
name now would have been a positive
maybe to bury some of
all the negative that we've heard from
this franchise or is now the wrong time
to do this because of all the negativity
associated with this franchise i would
say you know it would it would bury some
of the negativity because we would be
talking about the name although we're
talking about the name anyway and we've
it put some of the other stuff aside
just because we're sitting here talking
about the name but there has been so
much
negativity associated with this
franchise
that's a great point and here's the
thing
if you pick the right name it definitely
goes a long way toward turning the page
they're trying so desperately to turn
the page on a history of dysfunction on
a bad culture that
somehow daniel snyder bears no
responsibility for that inevitably will
be the result of the
of the investigation conducted by the
lawyer whose check
daniel snyder will be signing but
i have no faith in a daniel snyder-led
organization
to pick the right name see if they
actually this is
there's a little kernel of wisdom in the
decision
to just punt until next year or maybe
even longer
because chances are if they had picked a
name
now it wouldn't have been a good name so
let's stop let's wait let's just let's
let's
let's let's hang on here before we do
something rash
that may only make things worse let's
wait to pick a name so i
in a very reluctant way i'm going to
give
a daniel snyder-led organization some
credit for recognizing
yes they could have found a way to make
things worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports